UM...
[blows raspberries]
I'M DRUNK AS [bleep].
WHOO!
SO SHE WAS EXAMINED BY A DOCTOR.
LIKE, HOW TALL IS SHE?
AND THE NURSE WOULD BE LIKE,
COME AND LOOK AT HOW TALL
THIS NELLIE IS.
AND DOCTOR WOULD SAY, LIKE,
WHAT ARE YOU DOING
AFTER WE MEASURE NELLIE BLY?
AFTER THE NURSE AND DOCTOR
FLIRTED FOR, LIKE, A HALF-HOUR,
THE DOCTOR'S LIKE,
OH, MY GOD.
THIS NELLIE BLY,
SHE IS A CRAZY, CRAZY PERSON
THAT NEEDS TO BE HERE FOREVER.
AND NELLIE BLY WAS LIKE, YES!
I'M SO HAPPY.
I'M SUCH A GOOD JOURNALIST.
SHE STARTED TO SEE HOW [bleep]
THE CONDITIONS WERE.
THE NURSES WOULD JUST BEAT
THE [bleep] OUT OF PEOPLE.
KNOCK THEM IN THEIR EARS.
[blows raspberries]
HITTING THEM LIKE CRAZY.
LIKE, YOU WOMEN ARE ALL CRAZY,
AND YOU SUCK.
AND NELLIE BLY WAS LIKE,
AW, [bleep].
THAT AIN'T COOL.
I'M GONNA WRITE THAT DOWN.
THESE LADIES ARE GONNA GET
A WORD FROM ME.
SHE SEES PERFECTLY SANE WOMEN
WHO JUST DON'T SPEAK ENGLISH.
THE DOCTORS WERE LIKE,
WE DON'T SPEAK GERMAN.
YOU'RE CRAZY.
[blows raspberries]
YOU GO TO THE ASYLUM FOR LIFE.
AND THERE WAS A WOMAN,
SHE WAS LIKE, I JUST
GOT A LITTLE OVERWHELMED.
I'M NOT CRAZY.
AND THEY WERE LIKE,
THIS WOMAN IS IN--SO INSANE.
THERE'S NOTHING WE CAN DO BUT
KEEP HER LOCKED UP AT THIS
IN-SYLUM FOREVER.
THE INSANE ASYLUM WAS HORRIBLE.
AND THEN THERE'S THE--THE BATHS.
THE NURSES WOULD JUST SCRUB
THE [bleep] OUT OF THEM,
AND NELLIE BLY WOULD BE LIKE,
THIS KIND OF HURTS A LITTLE BIT.
SHE WAS LIKE, YOU BE QUIET
OR I WILL--I WILL--I WILL
MAKE YOU WISH YOU NEVER
SAID ANYTHING TO ME.
I'LL SCRUB YOU SO HARD.
- WOW.
- I GOT AT LEAST
TWO BATHING SUITS.
SHOULD WE PUT THEM ON
AND GET IN THE TUB?
- REALLY?
- YOU DON'T HAVE THE BALLS
TO GET IN THE TUB WITH ME
WITH A BATHING SUIT, DO YOU?
- [laughs]